[Music]
if you can get past the Bruce Willis
prosthetics congratulations movie asks
us to suspend disbelief on both
time-travel and telekinesis why not go
for the trifecta and add aliens any
movie that opens with three minutes of
first-person narration definitely
skipped the first day of screenwriting
101 this system of disposing of bodies
only works if there's an operational
incinerator plant completely abandoned
in broad daylight
so a stake is a sin whether it's in a
movie or real life why are there so many
early two-thousands model cars on the
road in the Year 2044 and how the fuck
that they figure out how to make cars
run for 40 years whatever this guy's
name is it should be discount Shia
LaBeouf even Joseph gordon-levitt can
fall for the old my favorite stripper
whore actually loves me routine Joe
almost runs over the whitest Ethiopian
kid you've ever seen what good is the
tarp if you're gonna use a gun that
blows dead guys off the tarp if it's so
tough to close your own loop one of the
mom guys just have one of the other
loopers kill future you and then give
you the nice retirement with none of the
guilt and he was there when they cut
this finger off as his younger self
which he was then this should not be
surprising this scene actually kind of
includes a lap dance so this is not a
sin move along I want to know what
happened to the plane that left that
contrail holy eyebrows Batman I mean
Robin
just because future Joe is delaying his
departure from the future doesn't mean
that his arrival to a specific time in
the past would be altered one bit this
is all the further cell phone technology
is going to advance in the next thirty
years
check it out gary oldman let him borrow
the Fifth Element weed young Joe
conveniently takes forever to simply
retrain her the weapon when he's later
shown to be able to do it very quickly
so in 2044 we still don't have decent
voice recognition software another
character surprised to see scars that he
gave himself the old Joe only ordered
his steak and eggs 30 seconds ago meat
that has only been cooked for 30 seconds
is not safe to eat I can remember what
you do after you do that is maybe the
stupidest time travel movie explanation
ever offered if disposing of bodies is
so fucking hard in the far future that
they have to send people back to the
past to be killed then why did they so
casually kill Joe's wife and for that
matter if they could dispose of her body
just by burning the place down then why
can't they do that for future Joe's body
Bruce Willis kills little kids and I'm
ok with it and I am NOT ok with that Joe
agrees not to talk to the kid and that
immediately talks to the kid she would
totally see him peeping in that window
worst peripheral vision ever
sweet thirty years from now we'll have
touchscreen computer monitors oh yeah
telekinesis don't forget that it might
become important suddenly personally I
love it when a woman tells a
heartbreaking and tragic story
immediately after sex Joan it's a Mario
star for invincibility and takes down
the entire enemy stronghold without a
scratch this is how the bad guys marked
the important location on the map
clearly nobody in the truck when it
wrecks know what of the grains okay here
we have a paradox of Terminator s
proportions since old Joe's attack
cannot be both the reason the Rainmaker
was created as well as an attempt to
assassinate the Rainmaker oh I think I
just remembered I shot myself thirty
years ago but still also today so will
Joe disappeared from the field I can buy
that but why is the fucking truck still
there and why did the lady of the
rainmakers still remember at all and why
does the kid still have a bullet wound
in his cheeky why are they even standing
in a field in the first place and why is
there gold in the road why the young
Joe's still there if he was only ever
there to stop old him and old him
doesn't exist anymore geez a hundred
bucks says this kid still grows up to be
a raging
[Music]
not the same pocket watches dad hit up
his ass in Vietnam